مرحبًا بكم في مطعم الدراسة الخاصة ،
بارك الله فيك في أي مكان أنت يا سيد فقط
أنا الله خلفك لأنه جاء
منذ عام ونصف قبل الكثير من الناس أكثر من
ألف شخص بالضبط لا يمكنني الذهاب إليه بالضبط
الكثير من الناس نعم
هذا الرجل جاء إلى هنا وقلت نعم لا  ليس
مستحيلًا لأن نظرة سيدي هي الدليل
الآن ، لا تكذب
يا ما شاء الله عزرا ، هل
أنا ماجد محمد ، أنا آسف من
80-82 والدي إلى هذا المطعم
وهذا هو اسم المحل القديم كان
كباب خاص  هو البابان والمطبخان
[موسيقى]
أي شخص يأتي هنا
وقد احترمهم ويعود بالطريقة الصحيحة وثق
بنفسك وثق بنفسك يمكنك فعل
كل شيء
مرحبًا بك في وسط
مطبخ بنغالور كولكا ، نختار عميلنا
بالطريقة الصحيحة لتقديمه  الكباب ذو
الجودة العالية في أوروبا الذي أعطيهم
حفلات الشواء باستثناء يوجا لحم الضأن واللبن
والدجاج التي أعطيها لهم ، لكن الجزء العربي
الإيراني الذي يقدمونه له
الزبادي أولاً هو Dell
الذي لا يمكنني قوله حول العالم ولكن في t  لقد كان أول
يوجا لحم الضأن والدجاج في الخليج في
العام ، لقد كان لدينا رقم واحد
وكان طعامنا عندما انتهى
، لم نكن متبلين مرة أخرى ،
قلت لا ، آسف على هذا الانتهاء
مرة أخرى ليوم غد بهذه الطريقة الصحيحة
الكثير من المطاعم التي يصنعونها  في نفس الوقت
الذي يجعلونه أكبر
، أنا آسف جدًا ليس جيدًا
لأنك ستفسد جودة اسمك في
طعام المطعم لمدة 40 عامًا
[موسيقى]
هذه كلها هواتف أو هدايا من
العميل لا ندفع أي أموال يدوية
رائعة بها عبر الإنترنت  هذه العملة
ملك والدي ، الكثير من الناس يأتون
إلى الأصل التجاري لأي عملة OE ،
لدينا أموال هندية
أموال إيرانية يضعونها ويتقدمون
في نظرية X foil ، ثم تضعها في
وضع أخلاقي ، هذه خسارة
منذ 70 عامًا  قبل ثماني سنوات ،
حكومة إيران ، أوه ، اسكت أموال دبي
، وكانت روبيةهم تعمل هنا ، نعم
، يبدو الأمر وكأنه متحف صغير
[موسيقى]
عندما يحصل كل الأشخاص الذين يرونه
على طاقات مطعم هو
بيتي هو موسي  لي  كل شيء
[موسيقى]